معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام
اذا وكان سيناريو الشفاء ومستشفيات اخرى
سيتكرر مع مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ما اخر
المعلومات التي تصلكم حول ما يحدث في محيط
المستشفى بالفعل هي حرب منذ البدايه على
هذه المستشفيات دخلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى مستشفى الشفاء ومن ثم
الاندونيسي ثم كمال عدوان ومن ثم محاصره
مستشفى الاهلي بعد قصفه وارتكاب مجزره فيه
والان على ما يبدو ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يكثف من قصفه في محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
بعدما منع وصول امدادات الطاقه وامدادات
الوقود الى هذا المستشفى وبالتالي اطفات
المستشفى بعد اكثر من 100 يوم وهي تكافح
من اجل عدم الوصول الى هذه النقطه نقطه
الكارثه بحق هؤلاء المرضى وهؤلاء الجرحى
وهؤلاء الاطفال الخدج الذين جميعهم يتواجد
في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هذا المستشفى هو
المستشفى الوحيد في وسط القطاع الذي يقدم
الرعايه الصحيه الذي يعتني بالمرضى هو
المستشفى الوحيد الذي يتواجد فيه اجهزه
لغسيل الكلى هو المستشفى الوحيد الذي
يتواجد فيه حضانات بالاضافه الى بعض او
مستشفى وحيد ايضا هو في مخيم النصيرات
لكنه بفعل القصف الاسرائيلي هو محاصر بفعل
استمرار الطائرات كوات كابتر اطلاق النار
على المواطنين الفلسطينيين الذين يدخلون
الى هذه المخيمات الفلسطينيه هم طائرات
كوات كابتر تطلق النار على المواطنين
وبالتالي لا يستطيعون الوصول الى هذه
المستشفيات مستشفى العوده كان مستشفى
وخصصه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه
للولاده الان هو يستقبل الجرحى ويستقبل
المصابين من جراء استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي هناك ضغط كبير على
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى من جراء استمرار هذه
الغارات الغارات مكثفه في محيط هذا
المستشفى الدبابات الاسرائيليه لا تبعد
سوى امتار قليله عن هذا المستشفى على شارع
صلاح الدين وهو الاقرب الى شارع صلاح
الدين هو يقع ما بين الزوايده وما بين دير
البلح وبالتالي منطقه اصلا دير البلح
يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي للسكان ان توجهوا
اليها والليله الماضيه ربما كانت واحده من
الليالي الاعنف على دير البلح بعدما شنتت
الط بعدما شنت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات على المناطق
الشرقيه لدير البلح قصفت ايضا بالمدفعيه
المناطق الشرقيه وشنت غارات مختلفه على حي
المشاعله وكان هناك عدد من الشهداء
والجرحى وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل الى في كل لحظه وفي كل حين هناك
غارات اسرائيليه وقصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه على منطقه دير البلح ايضا
مخيما المغازي والبريج يتعرضان الى قصف
عنيف وغير مسبوق من الطائرات من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه طائرات كوات كابتر تطلق النار
على المواطنين وبالتالي ما زالا محاصرين
بعدما تراجعت الدبابات الاسرائيليه الى
الحدود الشرقيه قبل يومين هي اعادت
الانتشار وعادت من جديد الى شارع صلاح
الدين وبالتالي باتت هذه المناطق جميعها
محاصره ويمنع التحرك على شارع صلاح الدين
وهو الشارع الاساسي والرئيسي الواصل ما
بين هذه المخيمات وهو يصل ما بين الشمال
والجنوب ما بين شمال القطاع وجنوبه وهو
يصل هو الشارع الاساسي للانتقال من مخيم
النصيرات من دير البلح من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى الى قريه المصدر الى مخيم المغاز
الى مخيم البريج وبالتالي الوصول الى هذه
الاماكن بات مقطوعا بسبب تواجد الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في تلك المناطق بسبب
استمرار قصفها لهذه المناطق وفي محيط
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ايضا مخيم النصيرات
يتعرض الى قصف عنيف يتعرض الى قصف غير
مسبوق محيط مستشفى محيط مسجد الدعوه في
مخيم النصيرات وهو يقع الى شمال المخيم في
جواره منطقه المغرا وايضا مدينه الزهراء
وجميعها تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا شنت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه احزمه ناريه في اكثر من منطقه
في مخيم النصيرات وفي دير البلح وايضا في
قريه المصدر وبالتالي كل المنطقه الوسطى
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه ومن
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا
المنطقه ربما الاخطر والاهم التي تتعرض
الى قصف من المدفعيه قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه هي
المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه لخان يونس منطقه
البطن السمين منطقه قيزان النجار وهذه
المناطق هي مناطق بدت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
بعدما تتوغل بعدما توغلت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه من هذا المحور باتجاه وسط
البلد في خانيونس وهذه المناطق تدور فيها
ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه سمع دوي انفجارات عده
في تلك المنطقه على ما يبدو انها ناجمه عن
تفجير المقاومه الفلسطينيه لعبوات ناسفه
وقذائف باتجاه القوات الاسرائيليه المتو
ايضا ما زالت المناطق الشرقيه رغم اعاده
تمركز وتموضع القوات الاسرائيليه في تلك
خلف قرب الحدود خلف هذه المناطق الا انها
ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف وما بين
الفينه والاخرى تتقدم الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تحاصر المواطنين الذين
يحاولون الوصول الى منازلهم وبالتالي
القصف مستمر ايضا في المناطق الشرقيه لخن
يونس بني سهيلا والقرار وعبس وخزاعه وايضا
الزنه وكذلك معا وكل هذه المناطق ايضا
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف ايضا القصف لم يتوقف
على مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع لكن هذه هذه
الفتره القصف مركز من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وحيث تشن الطائرات سلسله من
الغارات على مناطق مختلفه كما حدث في
الصبره وصباحا في حي الدرج حيث انتشل 20
شهيد من حي الدرج جراء قصف الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمنزل على رؤوس ساكنيه كذلك
هناك ثلاثه شهداء في منطقه بيت لاهيه وهي
من غاره من طائره مسيره وبالتالي القصف
مركز على المنازل مركز على المواطنين في
المناطق مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع وهي ايضا
مازالت محاصره ويمنع التحرك من الجنوب الى
الشمال من قبل المواطنين الفلسطينيين شكرا
لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
رفح